hey what's up my name's samuel leeds i'm
a property investor and right now in the
united kingdom but pretty much across
the world the property market is going
absolutely crazy so i wanted to report
right now with some facts about what is
happening in the property investment
space what house prices are doing not
just in england but in ireland wales
scotland also how the media are not
helping the situation and they're going
on about oh my gosh there's a boom
people aren't going to be able to afford
to buy houses they're going up crazy but
actually the media are part of the
problem not that it's a problem it can
be and this is the thing with property
anything can either be a problem or
solution when i was uh 17 18 years old
and the property market was crashing it
was a big problem and everyone's a
problem but it was also an opportunity
right now there's been a big boom it's
also an opportunity it depends on what
side of the coin you want to be on also
i want to talk about lloyd's bank oh my
goodness lloyd's bank are um going crazy
at the moment trying to become the
biggest private landlord in the uk which
i find very ironic because they're a
bank and i'm gonna be talking about that
and they're giving you some facts and
stats and information about lloyd's bank
and then lastly some people who are
complaining in plots of cornwall
near the beaches there's a lot of people
right now that are looking for bigger
houses second homes and we'll be talking
about that and the impact that is having
in the property investment space so if
you enjoy my youtube channel please do
me a massive favor smash the like button
if you're not subscribed subscribe and
turn on the notification bell because i
hit you with regular updates around the
property market every single day i'm
always putting content out and i'm
spending hours and hours researching
this stuff to help you in your journey
as a property investor so the least you
can do is subscribe so do that now hit
the like button let's get started let's
start by looking at some stats the stats
and the facts are that right now house
prices are have been rising at a faster
rate than they have ever done since the
year
2004.
house prices have been going up by 2
500 pounds on average
per month per house which means that if
you buy a house an average house for 250
grand that every month for the last 12
months it's been going up two and a half
thousand pounds on average every month
that means that if you just happened to
buy a house a year ago you've been
making two and a half thousand pounds
profit in equity every single month for
the entire last 12 months that is
absolutely crazy on average properties
have gone up by 13.3
in england in the last year in northern
ireland they've gone up by nine percent
which is still really high in scotland
they've gone up by 12
and in wales
wales has gone crazy the average house
in wales has gone up by
16.7
in the last year let me just let me just
get your head around that this is not
like bitcoin that's really volatile that
goes up and down really quickly this is
prop property prices going up by 10
15
bricks and mortar still getting the rent
of the property as well i mean listen i
was saying 12 months ago buy property
buy property and everyone was saying i'm
gonna wait i'm gonna wait i'm gonna wait
everybody that's waited is now saying
hmm
i've missed the boat maybe houses are
gonna go down they're gonna go down
they're gonna go down and the bottom
line is make sure that when you're
buying properties rather than obsessing
over what's going to happen in the next
6-12 months because you don't exactly
know you need to buy a property and make
sure that it's also giving you cash flow
and then if the value goes up brilliant
i actually hope that the value of
properties i hope the market corrects
itself soon i think it will i think it's
probably going to continue going up
but it's going to start slowing down and
then i imagine at some point in the near
future house price is going to start
falling and when that happens it's
actually a good thing because it means
that as a property investor
i can buy prop more properties and i can
buy them cheaper which means that my
return on investment is better so
whether properties are going up or
whether they're going down it doesn't
necessarily mean it's a good thing or a
bad thing you just need to know what
what's happening in the market another
thing is every area has its own economy
so even when i say england or when i say
wales
wales is a big place it's a country
england is a big place so for example
and you can look back at my videos from
a year or two ago i was advising people
to buy properties in the north west of
the country that's where i was buying a
lot of my properties we've been sourcing
and selling properties and a year or two
back i was saying
london isn't the best place to buy not
only is the return on investment bad but
it's boomed like crazy it's going to
correct itself and over the last 12
months let me give you the stats so the
north west of england has gone up by
over 18
that's even more than whales so all
these areas where you can buy cheap
houses you can rent them out high buy
low rent high top houses they have
exploded in in equity and london's only
gone up by six percent as opposed to
over 18 percent in the northwest of the
country so those are some of the
statistics over what's happened over the
last 12 months within the property
market but also what's happening in the
residential market why is this happening
why is london not being rising as much
as some other areas like the north west
of the country and what's happening is a
lot of people from within the centre of
london are moving out to other areas um
during the lockdown people are buying
bigger houses they're buying second
homes in fact i've actually got a news
article that's just come out right now
from my london that talks it it's
actually saying um
the beautiful seaside village in
cornwall where locals are desperate for
londoners to stop buying second homes
this is a really interesting story
actually i'll speak briefly about this
because effectively what's happening is
there's been an influx of outsiders
setting up holiday homes in the village
that's caused property prices to
skyrocket they then named the village
which is paul zeef i can't say i've ever
heard of that but it looks beautiful
it's in cornwall and they're writing
news articles saying telling the
londoners stop buying second homes here
and they're saying you know this is
where we've got we have a stunning
stretch of sandy beach um dubbed one of
the finest surfing beaches in the uk
it's no surprise that idyllic village of
paul zeath in cornwall has become a
tourist hub and then they're saying stop
doing it london stop doing it but it's
crazy because it's kind of like reverse
psychology because by telling londoners
stop buying second homes in this
beautiful paradise of an area cornwall
what's gonna happen is they're gonna
continue but these these kind of areas
are becoming really really really
expensive now
and you know a lot of londoners are
buying second homes it's making it's
making the villagers it's pricing them
out of the of the market however my
opinion is that the biggest crazy thing
that's going on right now is not london
is buying second homes you need to
google this go on google and search
lloyd's bank okay
lloyd's bank
lloyd's bank
and then
search news
okay in the news
look at the news stories about lloyd's
bank and you will see how they are
lloyds bank aims to be the uk's biggest
private landlord by 2025.
lloyd's bank are trying to become the
biggest unknown then we've got um
lloyd's bank aims to be a large uk
landlord with over 500
homes okay
this this in my opinion
i have a bit of a problem with this now
look this is just my opinion and i'd
love to know what you think in the
comments
my thinking is if lloyd's bank
of buying homes to rent out i see a
massive conflict of interest there
because they are
actively encouraging us
to put our money safely with them
and the fact that they are investing our
money
into buying homes and then renting them
back to us
and not a reduced rent
i just think it's such a massive
conflict of interest and not only that
but the fact that lloyd's bank are
trying to buy 50 000 homes
to rent out
that's going to push house prices up and
that's going to push people out of the
market they are a massive institution
who are spending hundreds of millions of
pounds advertising to joe blogs that joe
blogs should put their money with them
and then it
i mean i don't know about you can you
see the conflict can you see the
conflict of interest here now if lloyd's
bank was building homes that would be a
different story i hope they are maybe
maybe someone will come out and say no
they've changed their business panel
there because if they were building
homes
even me get this okay i'm just a nobody
i am
a working class guy
started with paper round money i'm now
30 years old i built a little property
portfolio i became financially free
enough for me to live a good life
and then i continued buying homes and i
continued buying homes and i got to the
point where i thought you know what i
don't need any more homes i'm getting
enough rent to be able to live a really
good life to be able to retire myself my
family my children my children's
children
what's the point in me trying to
monopolize the system and buy loads of
homes
what's the point of doing that and i
came to the conclusion instead of doing
that
i would build homes and now that's what
i'm doing because there's a shortage of
properties in the uk so to buy and
monopolize all the houses when there's a
massive shortage and when there's people
that can't afford to get on the ladder
and they have to rent
to buy and monopolize and then went back
to the people that can't afford and then
on top of that
use all the money that you're telling
people to invest safely with you and to
give them back 0.3 and then buy property
investments which are probably going to
give them a 10 15 20
i just see something twisted in that now
i don't know what you think and i am a
capitalist by the way but i believe in
um
compassionate capitalism whereby you're
actually adding value to the community
not monopolizing the system and actually
making it harder for other people so
i'd love to know your opinion on lloyd's
bank trying to buy 50 000 homes in the
uk and also having of you to become the
largest private landlord in the uk using
our money to do that i'd love to know
your thoughts and opinions um that's the
news what's going to happen in the
future listen this is what i'll say
make your own economy okay you've got to
create your own economy do not rely
off of the system the government and the
banks and the school curriculums
don't rely on what they tell you to do
for you to be financially independent
because if you follow the system you're
going to end up being a tenant in one of
lloyd's bank's houses
don't do that
educate yourself financially and that's
why i do this youtube channel i hope you
appreciate it and i'll see you guys real
soon
you